so much has changed bad bunny since i
talked to you in march it's kind of
crazy man
you tested positive for kova 19 how you
feeling right now
uh i i feel cool you know
yeah you're scared but but i feel okay
yeah
were you like worried at all yeah i was
worried i was scared you know because
we have uh we had a lot of plans and you
know
so i i was so sad because
we cancelled the amaze that's the
the worst part i know we missed you
how's gabriella and the rest of your
family everyone healthy
yeah yeah everyone is cool
yeah awesome well listen i know you've
been busy you put out an album
in may you're gonna put out another one
you put out three albums
this year so thank you first of all and
congratulations
we listen to your music everyone's you
know bumping it and jamming to it in
their car
some people are twerking to it but
there's always that deeper meaning in
your music
so what's at the heart of this album
what's the message
this new album is is gonna be like um
more with more feelings and
more from me it's totally different than
the other album the other album
is more like really a dawn and dancing
so this one the next the this
this album is more feeling you know it's
more
uh sadness and you know
[Music]
heartbroken so
i love it i love it it's dark
um it's dark yeah is up
pretty dark but we we with
feeling you know he i love it because
he's
he's like a part of me so
do you feel like we get to see a
different side of who bad bunny is with
this new record
yes yes i think yeah so what's the name
of the album can you explain the meaning
behind it
the name of the album is
that means the last tour of the world
because
it's not the last world tour is the last
tour of the world
because it's like the the last tour
from any artist is the last euro of the
world
you know after this tour there was
the word end you know it's different yo
no tour from lady gaga nothing
he's the last oh yeah that's it no no
one's hitting the road you know no one's
doing live shows anymore
do you miss performing live for a
stadium full of people
of course yeah any plans to do like a
virtual tour
i don't know i don't know because it's
cool
but but i want the people you know you
put out three albums this year i mean
are you just
constantly in the recording studio
working on new stuff for us
i always working you know i i'm always
creating
and it's my job and my passion
so when i work in
i'm doing music and where when i
rest or in vacation i'm doing music you
know
that's my thing so yes how has it felt
to
to lean on music to have music during
these challenging times because right
now
a lot of focus is on mental health has
music kind of been
something that has helped you and your
mental health yeah
100 yeah of course uh is
like a relief for me because when it
wasn't
quarantined you know the the only thing
that that i
had was the music and the music
and so i saw my mom
like the last time we spoke you told me
that you were in love
i'm in love i don't know you're in love
you still in love yeah i still
love feeling low
[Laughter]
even even during the pandemic how are
things going with gabriella during
quarantine
great
i think that was perfect my perfect
pointing
partner you know there was some talk
online a lot of fans
thought you were married because they
saw a ring on your hand can you set the
record straight
no i'm not married no
yeah are you engaged maybe you can be
there
okay yeah weddings and get married that
scare me
a lot it doesn't really yeah all right
let's talk about your other love
acting because when i last spoke with
you i asked if acting was in your future
and you said
yeah yeah i like to act yeah yeah i like
i like it hollywood he needs a role okay
yeah i'm here
not only did they hear you man they
called you twice
so let's talk about the role in narcos i
mean everyone on twitter
was so excited about that what can you
tell us about the role
so i i can tell a lot
but it's gonna be crazy you know
yeah i'm uh i'm a mexican gangster
you know with my gum and killing people
you got so much fun yeah yeah yeah i
love it
it's a great experience i always wanted
to
you know to make movies and
act so it's a dream come true
i'm so happy because it was your first
acting role
were you nervous at all yeah yeah yeah
i i i was so nervous but you know i was
working with a lot of
professional people good people that
helped me
and you know helped me a lot so
you were also cast in a movie with pete
davidson
uh called american soul i mean what was
that audition like
i mean did you were you nervous from
that process how did you prepare
no i always been able because it's not
my thing i i i had to i have to
learn a lot and you know practice
but i i feel so confident
that i can do whatever i want well
listen there's a lot to look forward to
next year i know 2020
looked a lot different than you probably
imagined or hoped
um what are you looking forward to next
year what does it look like what does
2021
look like for bad bunny for the 20 21
i think that right now my big
biggest dream is to make a concert
with a lot of people that's the only
thing that i want you know
i i know that it's hard but i don't know
that's my only goal right now really
as challenging as this year was
when you look back on 2020 what are you
most thankful for
for the new theme that i learned you
know
learn to to be more
lovable you know with my people and
because sometimes you you have
the people and and you don't say that
you love it and you know
yep oh that thing that i learned
um and obviously the the the
the health that i'm healthy you know i i
i have coffee right now but i'm very
still healthy i i feel good so
great yeah we're done and you're still
putting out some amazing music man
what message do you want to send to your
fans no that i love
all my fans thank you for for supporting
me for
for believing my music and
here we go again another album
i was gonna say are you gonna put three
more out in 2021 three more albums
no i don't know you're like i need a
break do you need a break
yeah i need a break well the holidays
are coming up congratulations happy
holidays and i appreciate your time
buddy as always thank you
very much thank you